hello everybody hello sorry sorry i was a little late there
guys uh oh my gosh chat's dead chat why are you dead what
did you guys do how did you guys die already okay give me a
sec i got revived chat give me oh my gosh okay my favorite
part was just like seeing you guys be like um the like
differences where one half was like she hates us and then
the intro started and then there's a guy right below was
just clapping like yay because the intro was playing and you
guys were like yay
oh my gosh sorry for sorry for starting off late there I
actually I had a I just got back from a meeting greet the
anime expo meeting greet and funny thing about it was that
um the um my event manager and I thought it was at 1 p.m.
because all the other stuff was at 1 p.m.
because like the panel was at 1 p.m.
and then like the karaoke was at 1 p.m.
and then like okay no no no no no no no no no no no no no no
no no no no no no no no no no no no no no no no no no no no
no that i can't read it's not that i can't read look it was
we we i i don't i follow i'm a good soldier i follow orders
and then and then later on later on i like woke up early and
i was like okay i'm ready for the tech rehearsal and then my
staff was like sorry joki it was actually four and i was
Like, what do you mean?
It was, it's been once this entire time.
One, one, four.
And so, so, like, I, obviously, I was like, oh, can we do it
early?
Like, if Dragoons got there early, we could start it early.
So then we, we started it early.
We started, we started the thing early.
So then we actually ended it, like, we ended it, like,
around five.
So I was like, oh, Thank God.
We actually made it in time.
And like, everybody, we met everybody that won the lottery
to do the meet and greet.
So, obviously, thank you for the 10.
Get the shares.
Thank you.
I really appreciate it.
Oh, my gosh.
For one of the, one of them was going to be a doctor.
One of the dragoons is going to be a doctor.
I met a doctor dragoon.
It's soon to be doctor dragoon.
She's going to raise the IQ average.
She's gonna raise our collective IQ average, guys.
There's a dragoon that can read.
We have a dragoon that can read.
It's possible.
Thank the Lord.
She can read.
She's gonna carry us, guys.
She's gonna carry us.
I was like, who do you think?
Who does she think she is learning to read?
Okay, I'm going to open a window right now.
It's like, oh, wait, the window is open.
Okay, that's bad.
All right, so we do have, all right, so for those who don't
know, we have an SMP now, and so we have a Minecraft server
basically for dragoons um it took a couple of um it took a
couple of months to do because there was like some coding
stuff that they had to do um regarding um so this server is
going to be like an ongoing server uh it's gonna be an
ongoing project so in that way where like we're gonna
improve more and more of it but it's at the stage it's at
the point of stage where uh where we can like Um, so, uh,
I'm really excited.
Uh, there are factions.
Uh, so there's factions involved.
And, uh, so you can separate yourselves into teams.
And it is four teams.
Uh, this is, this server is only the, uh, only open to
member, member goons.
Uh, because, like, um, it's been something I've wanted to do
for a very long time.
Like, longer than, I think, like, I'm pretty sure some of
you dragons remember me talking about how I really want to
do something I can now um this team that I've hired to make
the server they've actually done a lot of projects for like
um other uh other like big YouTubers other big Minecraft
YouTubers as well as like um tournaments and stuff for the
Minecraft community so like I trust them a lot to make this
uh a long ongoing thing um so the server will be open uh
forever I'm not forever but like you know what I mean but
like it's gonna be online for like like months and months
and months like for everything so so you can log in at any
time um there's only 250 slots though there's only 250 slots
of active players so you can log in at any time like even
though like but like there can only be 250 players on at the
same time um and so we have a white list as well um in the
future We are going, we're going to upgrade 250 to 300 in
the future.
And another thing that we're going to do is that we are
going to have a Discord server that's just for this
Minecraft server.
So the Discord server will be synced up with your YouTube
membership.
So like if you have a YouTube membership, you'll
automatically be able to join the server to like be
whitelisted into the Minecraft server.
That's still like in the works at the moment.
So we're doing it very like unga bunga caveman style where
you just post your username You post your username in the
community post and everything and then like you you get
whitelisted We're like doing it by hand like the whitelist
is by hand at the moment So yes, we will be like updating
this whitelist every month So like obviously like if your
membership expires then we're gonna have to because this is
reserved for like members and stuff.
We don't want a way for like, you know, have like the
whitelist being leaked or anything and stuff like that.
And there are rules to the server.
And we also have commands.
If you look at the community post, the members community
post, we have teleportation.
We have teleport commands.
If you have... because you can claim land.
So to prevent griefing, you can claim lands and and like
give permission to people to like do stuff on your land.
And then, like, oh my god, I feel like some of you guys are
going to start selling land.
The real estate next to Doki's house is going to go up by so
much.
There's going to be a town that forms around whichever land
I claim.
Anyway, you can claim a total of 100 chunks of land, and you
can set three different places as your home.
So you can TP to your home We also have resource worlds So
you don't have to farm the main world All you have to do is
slash teleport Resource All you have to do is Slash teleport
resource And you'll be transported to the resource world
Which will Which will What's the word Is a hundred chunks
Too huge?
I mean I could change it Right now Guys should we make it 50
i could tell them right now to change it to 50.
uh i just bought more lad all right i'll tell them right now
can we change can we change it to 50 no chunks instead of a
hundred people are saying uh look we're like figuring this
out as we go a lot uh a hundred is too much my land no keep
it to a hundred so I can so I can sell the land all right
guys I'm editing it's now at 50 chunks guys like I said we
can edit like the rules as we go along get mine for your
real estate all right anyway so So, alright, the thing, the
guy said that, we've already, we've made the change.
They're already made this change.
Anyway, um, so another thing is that, uh, you claim land,
um, and you teleport and set places to things.
Like, you can teleport to, uh, and you can actually, like,
request teleportation to other players.
Um, but, like, they have to accept it, basically.
have to accept all the commands are in the community post so
if you guys are like oh what are the commands and everything
there's also like private pm dms that you can send to other
players and also uh there are like you can apparently you do
slash sit you can sit down uh you will be handed three items
when you start those three items are related to like
claiming lands but it just makes it easier in terms of like
if you don't want to do the command system um you don't want
to do the command system you can use the items to command to
instead of the command like the slash commands and stuff um
we also have rules we have rules to the server so um
obviously uh for the grand opening there's no rdm what is
rdm rdm is like no random killing of other members because
we want to have like fun everybody have fun so no random
killing if you random kill kicking you out because a lot of
people want to get into the 250 slots so like no if somebody
complains and they got that they got randomly killed uh for
no reason you will be kicked and then a person will take
your place because we have a queue system um going in um so
yes do not build any lag machines if we find out you build a
lag machine you're kicked you're kicked out of the uh and
don't make like giant ass farms that could lag the server
like it could be like medium or small size but no like you
know those farms that you make a fucking pc like but for the
grand opening the grand opening we're gonna be like a bit
we're gonna be pretty strict on these rules um because
there's gonna be a lot of dragons we're gonna be able to
have a lot of dragons on at the same time so that's why
we're gonna be a little we're gonna be a bit more strict
going in at the moment for the stream.
Anyway, guys, I'm super excited because this is, like I
said, a very ongoing project that we're planning on we're
planning on upgrading and we're planning upgrading and
adding more stuff to it.
We're going to be changing the main lobby a bit because we
were expecting this to be done before my skin suit debut.
So there's going to be stuff that's going to be tweaked,
obviously, as we go on.
At the moment, factions wise um there's no like you don't
get like specific benefits for joining a particular faction
all factions are equal all and but when as soon as you if
you want to be like a wild dragoon with no faction you just
if you claim a faction you can't unclaim a faction you can
swap factions at any time though you can swap factions at
any time um but you can't unfaction yourself so uh if you
don't want to be in a faction you have to not press any
button all dragoons are created equally so like i don't know
if something happens where some dragoons believe they are
the superior dragoon that is like not my fault like uh i
literally said all dragoons are created and no there's no
like benefit being in one faction over the other so there's
literally like no no benefit in being like in a specific
dragoon role like they're all you guys don't get anything
special by joining one faction over the other.
It's just how you feel.
All right.
Anyway, so this is the, this is basically the, there's three
of these.
There's three of these.
You're all, oh my god, what is this fucking teletubby sun?
Okay.
I love the sun.
Anyway.
So there's the egg faction.
The uh regular goon the chunky goon and the long goon there
is like three of these so you spawn into three separate
areas for this and uh because like we don't want to have too
many people in like um there at the same time and you guys
get to claim your faction we do have a voice mod on the
server but i don't have it installed uh because i know it's
gonna get super chaotic with 250 people here But like if you
do want to like have voice mod on feel free it has its
proximity I put the link on it in the description in the
community post anyway, I think we're ready good luck
everybody We are ready.
Oh, wait, sorry.
We are ready Open open the gates Oh seven
God.
It is open.
Oh my God.
There you are.
Halloween.
Oh my God.
Look at it.
There's so many people here.
Oh my God.
Okay.
I don't know.
There are 343 players.
How's there 300?
How's there 300 people?
I don't know.
Oh my god.
How?
Selection mode to save.
Oh.
Okay.
Guys, I need to figure out how to mute chat.
Let me in.
Give me a sec.
I need to message them.
How to.
How to mute the chat.
There's a lot of people talking
Oh my god Oh my god Amused Okay We see people have already
selected their factions Help us
congratulations to like the people that made it oh my god oh
my god there's so many people here there's so many people
here all right option top oh i can toggle okay guys i'm
getting i'm being taught minecraft right now options chat
settings oh my god guys i'm figuring this out
I'll go from chat shown.
Okay.
Commands only.
Nice.
Check, check.
Oh, wait.
What the fuck?
Oh, what the fuck has made?
Somebody has made advancements.
Okay, give me a sec, guys.
I'm learning.
I did it, guys.
I did it, everybody.
Okay, now, now I can talk to you guys.
All right.
If you guys are still not whitelisted, feel free to update
replies.
in the comments um in the community post okay i need to get
the admin to tp to me can you can you tp me to the lobby
no you guys can all talk you guys can all talk and you guys
can listen to me You guys Whoa All right After After you
pick Your After you pick your Faction Everybody Head to zero
zero For the main lobby You gotta run here I couldn't So
we're gonna be redecorating this Into a saloon later To like
a a yihaw town in the future.
This was made during, during like when we were trying to
decide what to do during retro doki's time.
But this will be redecorated to yihaw land in the future.
So like the main area will be a saloon.
Obviously this one's just like your house now because it
looks like a dragoon.
But yes, I'm going to wait until like a horde of dragoons
come in.
Oh, wait.
Oh, is there motion blur on?
Oh, my gosh.
I have to...
Guys, I had to uninstall...
I had to uninstall everything related to Minecraft because,
like, my thing fucked up.
Like, I couldn't talk because there was, like, privacy
settings.
So I had to uninstall everything.
Where can I adjust the motion blur?
I hate motion blur.
Where is it?
Where's the motion blur?
Where is it, guys?
Is it in shaders?
shader pack uh no is it the shader pack settings custom
advanced settings oh my gosh i don't know there's so many
there's too many words guys there's so many words which
which one is it which one post process oh there we go off
there you go i couldn't tell right now i'm just overwhelmed
um do we get priority whitelist if super chat no magic thank
you for the super chat thank you thank you brother thank you
for the akasupa thank you thank you i really appreciate it
thank you so much all right that should work right all right
is there's motion blur no there isn't guys it's at zero zero
how far are you guys how far are you guys did i no there's
no motion blur i'm pretty sure did i did i fix it I can't
tell I can't tell Is there a motion blur That I hit apply
I'm at 10,000 Oh my god We spawned at 10k They're like 9,000
blocks away Alright good luck dragons Good luck
Holy shit You gotta 10k away from us okay that's pretty
that's pretty funny we definitely I think I want to do like
group chats I'm gonna ask I'm gonna ask can we can we do a
group chats uh for factions in the future and like a way to
make many group chats uh for people uh so like if you guys
want to like have I that's definitely something uh I really
want to do
We are at zero, zero, guys.
We're at zero to zero.
But I'm definitely, I'm asking if we can have, like, group
chats and faction chats.
And, like, you can group, like, if you just don't want to
use voice chat, you just want to talk to people via groups.
That's something we can do as well.
Oh, yeah, guys, you can do slash.
Guys, come here.
Come to the lobby, guys.
see what's the uh thing to show my skins again what's that
sound it hurts the thing what's the thing where i can show
you guys my skin you can when you need uh f5 is it f5 okay
guys look at this guys i'm a i'm a bear farmer again that's
look at that oh my god there's cinematic guys look i i
skinned a bear and put a hat okay wait sorry that's somebody
called some people call me the the bear hunting
right one out of 86 players are sleeping good luck with that
good luck convincing the other oh you made it you made it
wait no you're a wait a minute how the fuck did you have
like armor already how did the first dragon to have made it
over oh my can you already have armor oh my oh my god oh my
god bro it has speed running oh my god there's a there's a
lot how did you get how did you get armor ready those poor
dragoons are doing their trek over to like the promised land
they're doing their the chosen one they're like trying to
have over here right now.
Oh my god.
One out of 95 players.
Okay, I'm good.
Can we also have it so that only one person needs...
Okay, how about only a percentage of people need to sleep so
that the servant...
so that it's day not one because i'm wondering i think some
people would want to have it to be nighttime so like maybe
like one third like one third maybe
one third is a good amount i think um one third is a good
amount we only have like one drag how far is it how far are
all of you guys like 10 okay 10 um 10 percent don't worry
see we're like we're beta testing as we go along we're beta
testing now guys oh my god we have another dragon and chunky
goon and the long goon have made it and they have iron armor
guys guys other dragons the other dragons are not doing so
well the other you got diamond how regular guys we have
representatives from all that all dragoons except for the
regular goon like how does he have all the armor i mean how
do you have all the armor guys we're the regular dragoons
like where is he where is he this chunky there's line oh
there he is and you're naked Okay, you're...
That's a regular dragoon.
Guys, all dragoons are created equally.
Guys, I just need you guys to know that.
Every dragoon here is created equally.
But it does say something when the only dragoon
representative that's here is naked.
It does say something.
Regular goons are endangered.
But yes, we have the...
No, no, no,
no, no, everybody is created equally.
I'm really excited, though.
I'm really excited to...
Anyway, I talked to the team, and they will be working on a
chat system for all the dragoons.
Because, like, we know there's a lot of people chatting now.
So, you guys have to, like, be...
You guys have to...
slash resource kills you over and over okay thanks for
letting me know uh I'm gonna tell that to the like I said
we're like live checking it as we go along apparently slash
resource keeps killing people so this is like a stress test
we're stress testing everything at the moment um uh so it's
live beta testing but I'm really having I'm really glad to
finally have a server uh we've all of you guys it is um i'm
excited to like you know uh see what you guys come up with
and like see like things you guys are gonna build uh the
faction wars that's gonna go on
um um what the fuck
okay that's a long dragoon right there that's a long
Yeah, that's a long dragoon right there.
Um, all right.
It's gonna...
Um, it's gonna take a while for the other dragoons to get
here.
So this is gonna be the opening ceremony.
We have representatives for...
From everybody, from all the factions.
So we have representatives from everybody.
Um, but when you guys get here, just remember to, I guess,
like, set this place.
as like uh as a home area because i will be making
announcements here whenever i stream on this server uh or do
an event here this would be the main hub uh no way we had
this will be the the main hub so remember to set a one of
your homes here you have three homes so remember to set one
of them right here uh but it's great time i cannot wait to
see what you dragoons do uh we will have a implemented in
the future if you guys do have like future ideas that you
want to give regarding like um how the server will be uh run
and how like how what kind of quality of life features you
guys want um at the end of the stream feel free to comment
on some ideas and everything like um any events you guys
want to want and like any quality of life stuff any changes
you want to see uh just comment on the VOD later on in the
future after the stream ends you can comment on the VOD.
Anyway guys this area is 0-0 so it's at exactly 0-0.
Now run free.
Run wild.
Start claiming land.
It's a free server.
Well not free.
You guys have to pay to be here.
But start claiming land!
Go!
Claim the land for your people!
Alright, anyway, I will claim land too.
Alright, so I feel like people are going to start building
around my town.
It's time!
Somebody feed me!
Alright, go forth!
Alright, I'm going to claim a little bit.
of land um all right guys let's see so what you can do it
with the this tool oh wait there's a village next to us wait
that's so ideal wait we have a village next to us that's so
good all right let's see um for those who are wondering what
resource pack i use i use uh astra astrolux i think that's
what it's called what the fuck happened to that mountain um
Okay, there's an ocean here.
I don't want to claim there.
Uh, there's...
No, somebody has to feed me later, guys.
Right?
I am the mayor.
I'm the mayor of the server.
I'm...
No, I'm the president of the server.
I...
Sorry, I'm in Shader Pack.
I am the president of the server, guys.
Oh, wait.
Wait, no, no, presidents get reelected.
No, I'm not corrupt president.
I'm, guys, I am the, I am the queen.
I'm the queen of the server.
So that means, like, I'm in power forever.
You can't reelect the queen.
No, I'm not a dictator.
I'm not a dictator because I'm a, I'm a good person.
Where are you going to claim fellow dragoon?
Gangoon.
Where the fuck?
Where do I want to live?
I don't know where to live.
There's like so many... Oh.
Toxic.
Wait, is this your land?
Wait, that's so funny.
It's like, welcome to my land.
Oh my god.
Wait, that's so good.
I love that.
Like, it like shows now like that's so good wait oh feel the
wild oh no it's the pvp zone not the pvp zone okay no it's
the wild wait has music been playing this entire time oh
nice okay it has good all right the wilderness back to the i
love the fucking oh no oh no i love the like uh the sun You
know what would suck if, like, right underneath?
Wait, I want this to be my town.
Oh, this is going to be my area.
This is how I claim it.
I don't know if I'm claiming it.
Am I claiming it?
Am I...
Am I doing it?
I think I'm doing it.
Joki Birdo of Joki Birdo.
This is mine now.
I think Oh yeah This is my land I did it guys I Welcome to
my tiny land Welcome Wait I can rename it Wait okay there
were so many commands Okay home set Home tap to Okay let's
see uh tp land claim trust oh land rename okay i can rename
my area all right watch this i'm gonna rename my area now um
oh shit i disabled the chat whoops uh chat settings uh all
right okay slash land rename um Shit, what do I name it?
Doki land.
Is this it?
Am I...
Is it Doki land now?
Is it Doki land?
Is it...
Doki...
No!
How do I rename my land?
Land...
Oh!
Land rename!
Okay.
Doki land.
There we go.
Yay!
Is it...
work?
Wilderness.
Is Doki-Lan working?
Doki-Lan!
Oh my god, I did it!
I did it!
I got Doki-Lan!
Okay, let's like, get the fucking text smaller.
Let's...
Alright, let's see.
Maybe, like, off.
Does that work?
Okay.
It's okay, you guys saw the SMP because it's like no
accidentally disconnected oh my god don't keep that i'm back
i'm back in don't keep that oh my god okay yes oh my god
hello i oh my god okay by the way here's the tomatoes dude
we have tomatoes by the way okay i need more food guys i
need to be fed guys
I have priority queue, so, like, I get to be here.
I have priority queue, so everything's fine.
All right, so this is my land, guys.
It's, it's, it's the land.
Do you guys like it?
It's my land.
You guys can build a town around me.
One out of 21, good luck.
None of us have beds.
Oh my god, two people!
Two people are sleeping!
Guys, guys, I don't have a torch guys.
Wait, I need to get tools too guys.
Give me a sec a five.
Oh my god more people and you guys have beds You guys have
beds like what?
How do you guys have beds already?
How do you guys do that?
Okay, I need to make like a crafting table.
There's like I need so many things.
Oh my God we worked together we did the first task we worked
together and like created like and got and went to bed we
fucking did it guys all right six and I want to make a sign
okay all right Joe welcome to dokeyland There we go.
This is... This is the capital city.
This is... This is the capital city, guys.
Doki Land is the capital city.
And thus a town shall form around me.
Yes, it's still mine.
I claimed it.
You know it's mine.
Because the moment I...
leave it's the wilderness but then i leave here and then
it's civilization it's civil everything the light touches is
mine it's look rome started out as small okay guys rome was
a very small city okay um and then it got bigger and bigger
and then i have a bed this is pure civilization I literally
have a bed.
I need food now.
The scene up.
Oh no.
I'm in the wild now.
I'm in the fucking wild.
Rome didn't manifest out of nowhere.
Like it took years to build Rome.
Guys.
It took years.
Doki Lad is going to expand.
Okay.
This.
We're improving on Rome.
We're improving.
We're gonna be better than Rome.
We're gonna be so much better than Rome.
I need to kill a pig because I'm fucking starving.
Okay, wait.
Oh shit.
I need to go back to Doki Land.
My crafting here is here.
Doki Land.
Yeah, Doki Land wasn't built in a day, guys.
Alright?
We're at 1% of Doki Land.
We're merely 1%.
If you build, guys, if you build around Doki Land, you gotta
pay taxes.
yeah good i you know what whoever said that all right chest
uh all right okay wishes outside of dokey land all right
there we go there you go now you should be able to like uh
tack dokey land taxes
all right i wish i need to build another i need i need to
build okay let's see boom all right good thinking whoever
had the idea you were so smart all right guys what if you if
you build around doky land you gotta pay the doky land taxes
you you have to pay the doky land taxes I...
Yes, are you here to feed me?
Feed me.
Wait, I don't have a...
I don't have a fucking furnace.
Like, I think I have rocks.
You think I have coal?
Feed me coal.
What do you mean?
I don't have coal.
I don't...
All right.
Okay, I needed I was gonna make materials.
I was gonna make tools.
I wasn't gonna.
I wasn't gonna leach guys I know how to minecraft I'm not
gonna eat raw meat.
My god Caesar wouldn't have to eat raw meat
Whoa nice I found diamonds guys Here's my dokeyland taxes.
Oh God, oh my god the taxes taxes almost killed me greed
almost got me um Maxwell thank you for the super chat thank
you thank you oh yeah berries oh my god I can put berries I
would oh I could put berries around hello guys are you here
to pay tribute to doky land all right let's see I'm gonna
put this around Oh shit, that's not what I wanted.
I only wanted to eat.
I don't want it to eat.
Alright.
Nice.
How the fuck did you guys find all of this stuff?
Okay.
I hope someone builds like a coliseum.
Oh my god!
Guys, I found diamonds!
Okay, I think I need- Oh!
Okay, not again.
Okay.
Alright.
I'm gonna need some fucking...
I need some fucking...
Oh my god, I'm being fed.
Alright, let's see.
Alright guys, remember to put your taxes here.
If you guys want to give me anything.
Because you're getting taxed.
Let's see.
I need to build a furnace.
Furnace time.
Furnace.
I can't wait to see what you guys build, though.
And then I need...
oh my gosh i still need to all right boom all right that's
time to find has anyone donated coal yet no they've only
given me what am i gonna do with bread
you think i'm a bread leader guys i am a queen
you think queens live off bread
oh my god cool nice okay i'm gonna grab uh we get it bread
is for peasants damn right bread's for peasants you're gonna
give me a bread all right let's uh bread yeah bread is
actually really bad for breads i don't know you guys know
that all right let's see doki land Oh, I have coal now, so
We are finally Oh my god, what's in my The people see, okay
Oh, I have lily pads, oh my god, people I fucking have
fucking coal Let's go That's right I'm gotta Mud in now For
the queen For the queen Oh, no, I'm in the wild For the
queen of The server I'm actually really interested in seeing
what you guys do though.
My bread tastes so good.
Bread is poisonous to birds.
What does that say about you guys?
You guys want to poison me?
Look at this humble home.
I'm going to visit the peasants.
Hello, peasant.
Here you go.
You deserve a bread.
Oh my god.
Wait, I should like give bread to my loyal subjects.
I'm bad at the bread.
Bread is too good, too bad for me.
I should go feed the poor peasants that live around Doki
Land.
That should be what I want.
That should be what I do.
You know what?
That's a good...
What the fuck?
Oh my god.
Remember to pay your taxes, Ozzy.
Remember to pay those taxes.
Alright, there's like a lot of bread.
Okay, I'm ready to...
I'm going to feed the bread.
poor.
I'm gonna...
Don't worry!
My humble subjects!
I'm here to feed you guys!
Oh no, the wilderness.
The wilderness.
Bread is bad in Doki Land.
But like, I'm here to like, welcome.
Hello!
You poor Dragoon!
Do not worry, Dragon.
Here, have some bread.
Have some bread.
There you go.
You're welcome.
Remember what the queen did for you.
Oh, shit.
I need a...
I need a fucking...
I forgot.
I need a set home.
I need to set my home.
Guys, I need to be able to teleport back to my house.
uh yeah but it's raw meat i have cooked food i'm i'm such a
good queen i'm uh i'm for a season never eat the bread all
right let's see i need to make sure i set my house oh i
built that too okay all right let's see let me set home okay
how do i do this i need to look at my command Set home Doki
land.
All right, there we go.
Set home Doki land.
There we go.
That should have worked.
Okay, nice.
All right, I'm going to make sure it works.
Give me a sec.
All right.
T-P-O, home, home, home Doki land.
Oh, I did it.
I did it.
Guys, I have the magic power.
All right, let's explore around me.
Longoon Land.
Why is there a longoon Land?
Oh, my God.
All right, feel the wild.
Oh, my gosh.
The dragons are working together and sleeping again.
Go, dragon.
Go.
Make it day.
There you go.
Thank you for the super chat.
Thank you.
I'm so glad to be able to meet you at Anime Expo.
I'm so glad you love my doki doll.
I hope to see you next year, and thank you for all the
laughter.
By the way, here is my tax payment.
Thank you.
Thank you for the super chat.
I'm glad you had a great time at Mixbo, and it's great to
meet you.
Yeah, but where are the other goons that set up base?
Where are they all living?
I have Longoon Land, one of many.
Where do the other dragoons live?
Is there anybody living next to the village?
I can't believe we have a village right next to us.
That's so convenient.
It's actually 7k blocks away.
It's like the trek to Doki Land.
It's like an actual adventure.
The head chair.
The sacred land of Doki.
Make it 10k blocks away.
What the fuck?
Was this supposed to be here?
Who built this?
Wait, who lives there?
Who lives here?
Who the fuck James A.
Claimed?
You claimed the village.
Oh, that's evil.
Bro, he claimed an entire village.
That's so evil.
Oh my god.
actually claimed it.
Who made this?
This is a dock.
What's going on here?
Oh my god, what are you making?
Chunky-goon!
Don't worry!
I am here as your humble queen.
I am here to feed the poor.
Here you go.
You deserve it.
Go at it, soldier.
Come on.
It's in the name of Tokilad.
Oh, look at Amigo.
I'm such a good queen.
I'm making sure.
I'm making sure, like, everybody has...
Everybody has, like, the food they need to live.
Hey, you there!
You there, Cipher!
Here you go!
You deserve it!
so poor uh peasants that live around me in minecraft world
uh oh shit i pressed rx and refreshed my resources back oh
my god now i'm back in the wild wait who lives here who who
lives here oh my god nobody claimed this is this your home
is this your home
This was your home.
This
is now Doki Land 2.
Welcome to Doki Land 2.
okay dokey land to the sequel no shit okay dokey land to
it's our home now
welcome let me rename this land home um shit how do i rename
again land rename okay land rename dokey land two wait does
this like oh my god there's a tomato wait feel the wild does
it say dokey land still does it say dokey land guys i need
i'm testing out my land real quick guys i'm testing out my
land guys give me a sec why is my land not showing up Why is
my land not showing up?
I claimed this land fair and square.
I claimed it fair and square.
Where's my land?
Alright, let's see.
Why is my land not showing up?
I claimed it!
What did you...
I did!
I claimed it!
It was my land!
Oh, no.
Did I not claim it?
Did it got unclaimed?
Did my land got unclaimed?
Give me a sec.
There we go.
Slash claim.
Is mine now?
Oh, dokeyland!
There we go!
Guys, I did it.
Welcome to dokeyland.
is also dokey land now guys this is this is dokey land too
they worked so hard to build it but it's now mine i i mean
it's now mine egg town oh my gosh there's egg town i got the
dokey docks yeah i need the docks guys whoever controls the
water controls the kingdom have to know that if you control
the water you control the kingdom i need to be sure that
they know that they know holy shit how much would property
uh oh wait i should like make a sign to be like um welcome
welcome uh somebody make a dock next to my my land i need to
somebody to make a ship dock next to it uh of course there's
taxes the world is filled with taxes you think i wouldn't
tax my people i'm a queen
i'm the queen of course i tax people all right if you come
here from the ocean i need you guys okay i need a crafting
table give me a sec let me make a crafting table And then I
need a chest real quick.
Okay, chest.
Oh, shit.
Okay, give me a sec.
I need to fucking find some trees.
I need to find some trees.
Guys, look, being a queen is very, very hard work.
I need to make sure I have, like, a chest.
Alright.
Who is that place is this?
Thank you.
oh yeah i can do this because i'm the owner i can actually
other
people's bills because i'm the owner i'm like yeah you
thought this was yours i'm stealing me from another that's
messed up welcome to doky land i can't i can't i can't creep
other people's lands just because i'm the server owner it's
great i love being the queen all right if you what the fuck
okay all right build me a dock this is where the taxes will
go all right let's see i need a uh sign sign that's so funny
oh i don't have enough Fuck, okay.
Uh, I need more wood.
Alright.
I'm the HOA.
Revolution.
That's all I need to hear.
What?
You don't trust me?
He doesn't need this tree.
He's already rich.
He has an entire town.
He doesn't need this tree.
This wood.
tree like the HOA is back he doesn't need it like don't the
queen needs it more the queen needs this more all right okay
uh free the dragon from the taxation no
no you don't get to say that all right don't worry okay tax
time okay uh uh how do i do this taxes
all right there we go i gotta make sure i gotta make sure
all my dragons um live off well all right let's let's
explore more it's fun seeing what you guys are up to I got
feed I got to feed the peasants around my kingdom Guys Guys
I gotta make sure the peasants that live around my kingdom
Are having a good time Hello fellow peasants Hello I am here
to grant you Get out of the screen Get out of the crafting
Get out of the crafting Listen to me I am your queen you
gifts eat eat my present all right oh my god somebody's
planting bamboo
nice my bamboo wait who's building a fucking tower oh oh my
okay all right um that scared the shit out of me wait who
lives here
Did no one claim this land?
Who lives here?
Who lives in...
Wait, who lives here?
This is not claimed officially.
Oh, the...
Okay, we're gonna leave.
Take me back to the wild.
Germany!
Why?
Who's building a country?
What the fuck is Germany doing here?
here what is oh my gosh my people my people kill him okay
nice all right i shall feed my peasants don't worry don't
worry peasants don't worry i shall make it rain oh
my gosh i'm such a good person i'm such a good queen i think
i think i'm a Oh, wait, someone got an alloy.
An alloy?
Somebody got an alloy already.
It's gone.
Oh, my God.
Look at me go feeding my hungry peasants.
Feeding down with the queen.
Oh, my God.
I'm glad people are enjoying it.
Oh, my gosh.
There's a chicken.
There's a chicken here.
There was a chicken.
heard it i heard it die there was oh faction are you a
hermit you're living so far hello your queen is here to
welcome you to doki land eat eat oh my god this guy's a
hermit it's so cool to explore with everybody why there's a
black sheep here too do they claim that jungle?
Yeah, they live in the jungle.
Those wild peasants.
Barbar- Look, they might be a barbarian dragon, but they're
still a dragon in the end.
I wonder if anybody has claimed land from all the way there.
Oh!
I hear like some of you guys are really far.
I'm gonna- okay, I'm gonna ask the admin.
I'm gonna- wait, okay.
Okay.
admin um admin can you tp me to the far far uh claim what's
the dragon faction area faction area i want to see the
dragoons from a from a far i want to see the dragoons that
have conquered the land from way far.
What the fuck?
Who claimed this one tiny area?
What land did you claim?
What the fuck kind of land did you claim?
What did you...
What is this house that you have?
The Fargoons.
I want to see the Fargoons.
Oh my god.
all right it's time to tp what was it i keep always having
to remember home home home doky land i'm back home i'm back
in the doky lands oh my god look i got a flower
let's see let's put this banner here so you know okay you
know we're good people Yeah, the smaller spawns.
The dragoons that spawned 10k blocks away from the lobby.
Wait, I want to add a note here, too, for us.
Oh, okay, give me a sec.
I'm going to add a note.
uh server is only open to member dragoons join the members
to join the dokey dragoon smp okay there you go oh let me
make sure it's like all right so people know people will be
like well how do we join you know it's really tiny but now
you know become whoa
the queen is here hello chunky good hello the queen is here
to say welcome the the dragoons from the land of far
from the far your queen is here to welcome you all
the fargoons you know you guys you guys are all right you
know you guys are like I'm like in England right now and you
guys are like in America you know like but you guys won't
rebel you guys won't rebel like i'm like america yes from
the across the ocean did you guys claim any land oh my god
did you guys claim any land they look the austria yeah these
guys are like uh the americans whoa oh guys oh guys what's
going on
lives everybody sit around me guys i'm not doing okay so
please sit around me sit guys sit slash sit guys i need you
guys to all slash sit the queen is here i traveled all
across the ocean slash sit for me slash sit yes sit down
everybody the queen wants to talk sit down Slash sit, guys.
Slash sit.
We're back.
Guys, we're back again.
Nothing.
I don't know what happened.
My internet was being fucking crazy just then.
Anyway.
Alright, everybody.
It was great.
It's great to see the dragoons from afar.
Guys.
need I need take me to your land where did you guys set base
also the queen grants you food I am a nice queen I am a good
queen anyway guys I need to know I need to know guys show me
your land show me your land I want to know what you guys
built uh I need to know what have you guys built what do you
guys show me where you've claimed your land what have you
built guys show there is no Or embossing, say.
Thank you for the Aka Supa, Maxwell.
Thank you, thank you.
All right, I'm going to follow one person.
Have you built something?
Do you have something for me to show?
No?
Are you just following me?
Okay, oh, this guy, this guy has something to show.
Do you have something to show?
You do?
All right, what do you have?
You don't?
Are you guys all homeless?
You guys had so much time to build some- America!
What are you guys doing, America?
I left you guys alone and you have nothing to show me your
queen is not happy
I can't believe it I can't believe you guys are homeless I
am disappointed the queen is not happy so much time and you
build nothing?
You guys build nothing?
There's so much land around you.
What do you mean you guys build nothing?
What do you mean?
Yeah, let me where's your base?
You didn't even claim any land!
Drug American goons!
You didn't even... Germany has land!
my king my king germany had land where's your land where is
I provided you guys a home we need a public housing that's
too much to ask for I'm alright your queen is a little
disappointed
I'm a little disappointed in you guys The dragoons from Doki
Land have already built so much.
America, I left you guys alone for like an hour.
And there's no mega house yet?
I don't understand.
That's the old.
Not even a dirt house.
There's no land claim anywhere.
There's no...
I'm just saying I'm just saying The goons back in Dokilan
The goons back in Dokilan They've already built So they've
already claimed Everything around Dokilan but like Oh my god
I sent you guys away To the new world I sent you guys away
to the new world And you guys didn't have anything To show
for me you pay for the taxes how would you pay for the taxes
in the new world
all right i'm going back goodbye american dragoons goodbye
new world dragoons you've disappointed your queen
goodbye i forgot the commands for this again there we go
back to doky land we go Hello, have you guys given your
taxes back?
Look at these civilized goons that have built stuff around
Doki Land.
Look at that!
This goon has a house foundation already set up.
I see the houses in front of me!
The New World goons knows what's up.
I mean, sorry, the Old World goons knows what's up.
made it no taxes without representation thank you miracle
for the super chat thank you thank you all i'm saying is the
old world dragons know what to do look this guy has a home
it's a shitty home but it's a home all right like
like look at these guys they know what they're doing it's
not stealing it's taxes uh it's luthuania there it's not
stealing it's just taxes it's really nice to pay visit um um
just so luthuania's iron yeah tell that to the british
the queen requires the queen requires uh oh wait oh is that
a bird oh my god is that your bird oh it's your bird oh
that's so cute oh you can't make it dance yet though it's
different
all right i want to see if anybody built a dock yet um it's
fun i'm so happy i'm so glad you guys can play on the server
with me um i can't wait to like do more what the fuck is
this what the fuck is that what is that port eggs an egg
town egg town and port eggs all right let's see oh my god
Coyote Like how people have already built Dookie land too
Where I stole from Miku What is this?
The Chonky goons have something else to say about that Long
goons have claimed this dock Wait what?
This is a dock for everybody Oh are you guys actually making
a ship dock?
What is this?
Porta-Tet may put it
What is this saying?
What the fuck is that?
I can't...
They're trying to make a word.
I don't even know what word they're trying.
Oh, talk.
Is that...
What's that word?
D-O.
Oh, it's a D-O-K.
Oh, it's Doki!
Oh, that's so cool.
Somebody, poor guy, who was trying to make a dock and it got
claimed.
Doki can't read.
You guys already know that I can't read.
Like, it's not new at all.
Sorry, I'm not actually playing Minecraft.
I'm just exploring.
It's fun.
It's fun seeing what you guys are doing right now.
I am James of the IRS.
I own the village now.
as legoland which is at spawn you owe me one diamond for
that one take it illegally who said that james this is your
town thank you the super chat thank you thank you this is
your town don't make me kill this villager right now james
nobody governs queen dokey do you i can make i can get now I
can I can get Clint right now and there will be no village
you won't want that James oh my god wait somebody's already
kidnapping your villager James your villager's getting
kidnapped oh my god they're kidnapping your villager
Kidnapped your villager, James!
James, you're not doing so well.
You already took your villager away.
What is this guy trying to write?
What is this?
What is this guy?
It's called...
Oh my god!
He's rowing away!
Very slowly.
They're going to escape in three or four business days.
Hurry, James.
Oh, hey, look, everybody's here.
Welcome to the lobby.
Welcome, everybody.
Are you guys having a good time?
Welcome.
This is the lobby area.
We're going to upgrade this more later on.
No, it's an arranged marriage.
We watched the kidnapping live.
on stream oh my gosh it's been pretty fun so far oh should
we kill the ender dragon right now guys let's do it should
we do it would be so fun we all just like went to the ender
ender world and then killed it in like i'm pretty sure
somebody has already killed the ender dragon like oh there
oh my god is this all your land Is this all your land?
That's fucking insane.
That's a lot of land.
Yo, the last time, like, the Minecraft dragoons that broke
into the server, because our whitelists fucked up, they,
like, they killed the Ender Dragon in, like, two hours.
So I won't be surprised if they're almost there.
All right.
Let's go kill the...
We need public housing projects for the new world.
well what what if you guys better build it you think i'm
gonna build it like
you think you think i'm gonna build public housing that's oh
my god there's your chickens what if they follow me
What about me?
I'm not a bad person.
It's okay.
Go lead your chicken over here.
Mine now.
Alright, let's see.
Oh my god, I have more food.
I have more food.
all right all right guys whoever wants to beat the ender
dragon go to the lobby for those who are 10 000 blocks away
i'm sorry new world goons but like we'll meet you in the
ender world uh go to the new world goons will meet you in
the ender in the ender world for now anybody everybody at
the old world old world.
They come to the lobby.
You even know where the portal is?
Somebody has to know where the portal is.
Alright, guys.
Everybody.
Alright, let's wait until they sleep.
When they sleep.
Alright, guys.
You guys ready?
You guys ready to kill the Ender Dragon?
Are you guys ready?
Yeah!
Alright, who knows where the Ender Dragon is?
Guys.
guys who knows if you know where the ender dragon is uh all
right come over here come over here guys all right everybody
come here come here all right if you know where the ender
dragon is i require build a build a pp tower right now so i
know who to follow uh
if you are one of the one of the dragons that know where the
ender dragon is i need a pp tower so I know which which one
knows give me a PP tower so I know you guys you know where
the dragon or the Ender dragon is somebody must have figured
it out by now
did anybody figure it out are none of the speed runners in
this in this area are they in the new world all the speed
runners are all in the new world god damn it we sent the
wrong Oh my god.
Did we send the wrong dragoons?
No one knows.
Alright.
Does anybody know where that fucking Ender... Is there no
Peepie Tower anywhere?
I'm stuck with the old word.
Dragoons!
Is there no dragoon with a Peepie Tower that knows where the
Ender Dragon is?
Oh Wait, okay, wait.
Oh, this one!
These guys!
Alright, who do we trust?
We have two dragons.
Okay, we have this one.
What's his name?
What's his...
What's your name, sir?
We have an egg gun?
What's his name?
What's your name, sir?
Alright, L for demon.
And then we have...
We have Tommy.
Alright, it's Tommy versus L.
All right, guys, we're gonna have a poll.
We're gonna have a poll.
His poll, his PP is bigger.
All right, actually, whoever has the biggest PP tower will
lead us to the Ender Dragon.
Whoever makes the biggest PP tower gets to lead us to the
Ender Dragon.
Them Tommy has iron, so I trust him.
Oh, you better hurry.
Only the biggest PP Tower can lead the... Okay, he took and
made it.
Is that really the biggest you have?
Is that really it?
Okay, well, we definitely know who's the winner here.
This guy stopped.
He stopped building.
Okay.
Tom Tommy's gonna win I think I think Tommy's gonna win all
right Tommy that's okay you can stop now Tommy he can stop
now Tommy we will follow you to the ender dragon somebody
like the bottom of fire that'll be so funny is it why flint
it's okay Tommy lived he lived Tommy wait where did Tommy go
he lived guys Tommy actually lived to it up all right Tommy
where did Tommy go where did he go he did Tommy lead us to
the ender dragon wherever you are wait i i yeah he lived i
saw him the other guy died but i saw tommy live all right is
that tommy the tommy is tommy trying tommy trying to lead us
right here oh my god tommy tommy where are you tommy there's
so many people tommy wait did he actually die oh shit wait
then who's gonna lead us oh well if Tommy died we have a new
leader now this guy this guy whoever you are you shall lead
us to the ender dragon
take us to the ender dragon look all right all right he's
dead too okay All right, you there!
Cosmic!
Fight.
Elimination.
You get to be the leader, Cosmic.
Take us to the Ender Dragon.
We're going to follow you.
Cosmic, we're all ready.
Where is it?
Oh, Cosmic, he doesn't know.
He didn't even know.
We don't have actual leaders.
He doesn't even know.
He's like, wait, I was just joking.
Because he was just joking.
Oh, this guy right here.
He has his own PP.
All right.
You there.
You've done it.
You are now the leader to take us to the Ender Dragon.
All the other ones died.
So congratulations.
Congratulations.
You there.
the other leaders and the dragon leaders died oh oh guys
like because i don't think we're gonna be led i don't
guys i think this position is cursed guys i think this other
than cosmic who was who did not have the credentials cosmic
had no credentials to be a leader and was lying this entire
time we don't have anybody to lead us guys everybody who has
a pp tower has so far like failed us um oh my gosh whoops
you there you do you know where the ender dragon is come
down you're the new leader now this time it'll work come
down don't build it any taller We've seen we've seen what
happened Come down We need you to lead us You must know
where the end of dragon is Come down but not too fast
Okay this is Alright you're the closest Okay you're the
closest to the ground Yeah I'm a bro Alright now you're the
leader Yeah I'm a bro Alright you're the leader now all
right yama bro take us to the ender oh it's right underneath
us guys it's right underneath us go if we all dig together
we can get to the we can get underneath all right oh guys
guys that's our leader guys that's our leader guys we're
here that's our leader keep digging keep digging we need to
dig dig down right now everybody dig down that's That's
where the Ender Dragon is!
Dig down!
The Ender Dragon is right below!
Dig, dig straight down!
That's where it is!
Off to the... I swear, I swear if the New World Dragoons
have made it to the Ender without us, I swear to God, guys.
I swear to God if the New World Dragoons have made it, made
it before us.
Oh my god, there's water here.
Guys, I don't...
Guys, what do we do?
What do we do?
Guys, I don't think we planned this very well.
I don't think we planned this very well.
Yammer, bro!
Where's the end there?
Where is it?
Oh, it's meat.
I'm fine I'm I'm well where is it oh my god the guy with
lava oh shit are we going what the fuck we okay I guess
we're going to the end all right we did it now what now what
do we do
You know...
Yama Bro knows what they're doing!
Oh, sorry.
The Nether!
We're going to the Nether!
Guys, the queen has, like, had to do a lot of stuff today,
okay?
The queen has been through a lot.
Oh, no.
Guys, I can't move up.
Somebody will take this.
Guys.
please somebody oh okay nice okay all right where do we go
this way all right guys we can't let the new world the new
world goons beat us to it guys guys we can't let the new
world dragoons beat us can't let america win we
the wind!
We're the old world dragon!
Okay, get it.
Wait, where did Yamabro go?
Where did Yamabro go?
Where did he go?
Oh, over here.
Down here.
Okay, follow the pathway.
You'll be pussies.
Yeah, oh my god, that was half HP.
Okay, maybe a little pussy All right, this way guys this way
This way guys we can't let them beat the ender dragon Whoa
What happened?
They're so what did that?
Who fucking put a bed down?
head down.
What the fuck?
Oh god.
Where are we?
Oh.
Did he do it?
What the fuck was it the new world dragons?
Oh shit.
Did they do it?
made it to the end where is it we lost yammer bro where's
yammer oh wait they opened the portal guys they haven't done
it yet guys they've only opened the port who are we
following who are we following like we lost the leader guys
we lost the leader guys we've lost the leader guys where did
he go oh wait i got tp you're right guys tp to uh yeah
goodbye guys sorry i messed it up tp yam bro i tp you here
now lead us oops i replied oh my god now lead us guys guys
you know where you do know where we're going right you know
where it is right you actually
yeah bro we guys we they're not gonna defeat the they're not
gonna defeat the ender dragon without us guys okay they're
not gonna do it wait what what where is where are they
taking us it's okay don't mind him we have an army swear to
god if he's like all the other competent leaders die
all our other confident leaders have died all we have is yam
bro looks lost they built the pp tower it was the shortest
pp tower ever built but they still built it like It still
happened.
Okay, I'm not standing near the edge of this.
Oh,
whoa, whoa, whoa, whoa, whoa, whoa, whoa, whoa, whoa, whoa,
whoa.
Okay.
All right.
Give me a sec.
I need a...
I fucked up.
All right, there we go.
All right.
Whoa!
Okay, that was close.
Does he...
Does he know where he's going?
Look, all the other leaders die!
all we have now we compromised we got from eyes we had the
compromise okay all the other ones died
all right i think he knows what he's doing because i think
he knows what guys he knows what he's doing guys Like, look,
he has a set-up pathway.
So, like, surely, right?
Guys, I fell.
Where did he go?
Oh, there he is.
Where is he taking us?
Guys, where is he taking us?
Please!
The New World Dragon Wars!
We didn't get there before the New World Dragon Wars!
We can't let the American goons win.
Please.
I called them uncivilized.
They're gonna try and do a revolution if they find out.
If they beat the end before the rest of us.
They're gonna...
They're gonna try and succeed from Dookilad.
is fine guys it was unlucky that like the other the diamond
dragons uh in the old world died from the pp tower that they
made oh shit don't go up don't
dunk the lava he dunked the okay it's time to tp again uh
um what was it uh doki bro wait how do you tp with me to the
other person like how do i no that wasn't yam bro how how do
you how do you do you do the tp to person how do you tpa oh
tpa yam bro am i there wait where did it wait did he die oh
where is it where is it yeah it's just you and three people
only there's only three
oh my god wait did i do tpr oh oh
guys we did it guys
I fucked up a little.
It's okay, guys.
It's okay.
We're all here for the journey.
All right.
Where do we go?
Where did you take us?
How am I going to go home?
How do I get home?
What do we do now?
This has been a terrible expedition.
This...
Different.
You fucked up.
Whoa.
I don't think you actually knew where it is.
I don't think.
Yeah, bro.
I don't think you even knew where the end is.
Oh,
there's a portal!
Wait!
What did Yambro do it?
This is where we came from?
This is where we came from.
Why are we...
Yambro, why...
Why are we back here?
Why?
Alright, where's Yambro?
Where is he?
Where's Yambro?
Where is Yambro?
Where's yam bro?
Wait, where's yam bro?
I need yam bro here right now.
All right.
All right, guys.
If anybody...
Yam bro.
Yeah.
bro
all right where did yam bro go yam bro all right everybody
wait yam bro wants to redeem himself yam bro are you taking
me to the are you redeeming yourself all right yam bro has a
place to take us all right maybe it's not over yet for
maybe it's not over for yam bro maybe he has something he's
cooking right now he's cooking no he has somewhere to bring
me right right yeah bro did you take me somewhere yeah we're
gonna take me no no no he's walking back we're back in
Germany now and now we left Germany okay we're gonna let him
cook he clearly has he has an idea he has he has an idea
right now what is your idea you're making chicken
yeah bro i'm i don't know man i yeah bro i i don't know
anymore i don't know if you're actually cooking He made it.
He made chicken.
Okay.
He's made.
He's made chicken.
All right.
I believe in yam bro.
Guys, guys, I still have faith.
I still have faith, guys.
At least he's got, he knows what he's doing.
Guys, you guys are doubting him, but he knows what he's
doing.
He got...
I think we're just...
Guys, he clearly knows what he's doing, guys.
He might have taken us in the circle, like, during the
nether, but it's okay.
I fully believe in him.
He has a goal.
Alright, oh my god, and he remembered not to do that.
That was...
He clearly has a goal somewhere.
He has... somewhere, right?
now where where is it yam bro where are you headed the
adventures of yam bro
the new world always the new world that you guys haven't
killed me there's no way you guys killed the ender dragon
yet old world don't you disappoint me old world the new one
you had the way the new world to wait for us where the fuck
are you go why do you need a tree where
are you crafting what are you guys i don't know i'm sorry to
trust this plan less and less they both okay all right yeah
bro row us to the end it's been like the new one has been at
the end for like 20 years now
i've just been tagging along row us to the new world
how you can't say it was my fall.
I literally was like alright guys, who knows where the end
is?
Whoever has the biggest PP tower gets to take us to the new
world.
Not new world.
Gets to take us to the end and beat the new worlders.
But then everybody died.
He was literally like the last person left alive.
It was, I could not do anything else.
He was literally the last one.
Alright, where is it?
I I didn't decide to follow him.
We had no other choice left.
All our other picks died from mysterious circumstances They
all died mysteriously.
How the fuck was I supposed to know?
Oh my god, wait somebody lives here?
Who the fuck lives here?
Let him cook.
Mario, thank you for the super chat.
Thank you.
Are we like no, we're are we in Europe?
Guys, the UK is not in Europe anymore because of...
Because of Brexit.
We're back in Europe, guys.
The Fargoons.
Alright.
Does he know?
Dude, somebody's dog is here.
They brought their dogs.
Is this like, wait, is this it?
Wait, is this it?
Oh, shit!
Wait, what the fuck?
Why did you...
Why did you take us to the...
Wait, why did you take us here?
Bro, why did you take us to a fucking...
Okay, we're like...
We're just...
We're literally just...
What do you want me to have this?
Literally have this mad cyborg rapture.
Why did you take us to the jungle temple?
What the?
I am...
I don't know, guys.
I'm trusting this process less and less right now.
I don't know.
He stopped for a temple.
I don't think he actually knows.
Guys, I'm starting to think he doesn't know, guys.
I don't know.
I'm starting to think he doesn't actually know where it is.
What's that for?
What's...
Yambro, what?
What's that for?
It's over, Yambro.
Alright, new leader time.
Built the biggest...
Longest PP Tower.
It's over for Yambro.
His journey ends here.
His journey...
I need a new leader The new leader Give me a peepee tower
you actually know Give me a peepee tower If you actually
know where the end is Alright You there What's your name?
What's your name?
Wi-Fi Alright Wi-Fi Take us to the fucking end
Oh shit JK No you sir Over here This guy.
This guy.
You.
You over there.
You're the new leader.
Take us to the end.
The new world would like to declare.
It's not over yet.
We haven't made it.
Alright, this guy.
Get down here.
The new world.
We gotta beat the new world.
Oh, he lives.
Alright.
Corvo.
Show us show us where it is if you don't know where if you
fuck us over I'm in at the time to feel the air Bro yeah bro
was fucking baiting us this entire time Oh my god he was
actually baiting us Oh my god are you fucking kidding me
Holy shit!
He was actually painting us!
Oh my god!
Okay, I'm gonna fucking mooch off your boat, sir.
Project, give me a sec.
Alright, follow him!
You let that new- I can't believe it!
He was a New World spy!
I'm calling you now!
He was a fucking New World spy!
He did it for the new world Now the sleeper agent Follow
that man over there Follow core or something They told you
since I can't believe it Follow him He knows the word the
end is If we doesn't, we know what we do to spy.
I should have killed him when we came back from the nether.
But you all told me to give him a chance.
You all said, you know, believe in him.
He's not fucking you over.
Believe in him.
I fucking knew it.
I knew he was a spy.
Follow him He knows where it is He knows He must know where
it is I believe in him I believe in our new leader That
temple was good Bro they give us a super chat They give us a
new thing This is it That's a new ender portal A new another
portal Oh Someone made another portal here.
No BGM.
After what Yambrot did to us, we don't deserve BGM.
Alright, guys.
Don't worry.
Guys, we can't end stream until we defeat the Ender Dragon.
Guys, we can't.
You guys haven't won yet.
You guys haven't beat the Ender Dragon yet.
Yes, haven't done it yet.
No, we're doing this legit.
We're doing this legit.
He knows where it is.
He knows.
Corvo knows.
Corvo, what do you see?
What do you see, Corvo?
Do you feel the stronghold?
Do you feel it?
You...
what does he feel does he also feel the air wait i lost
where did corville go why are we killing cows where did the
corville go where did the fucking where did the monocuma go
guys
guys guys guys
What's that?
No, I don't know where you're talking.
That was my BGM, guys.
Guys, we don't know exactly what that sound could be.
Guys, we don't know.
Guys, it's not over yet.
Guys, we don't know what that sound was.
Okay, that's not Corvo.
Okay, that's okay.
That's not him.
Okay.
Guys, we don't know who that was.
That could be anything.
We don't know if it's a new wargoon.
They have to send a pigeon letter.
Guys, we don't know yet, guys.
We don't know yet.
They haven't had their tea party moment yet.
We don't know.
That could have been anybody.
Guys, I lost the guy.
I lost him.
It's too late.
I lost.
Oh, sleeping through this night.
Oh, wait.
A moment in the daytime.
We'll see.
Yeah, that could have been the wither.
We don't know yet.
Yeah, that could have been anything.
We don't know exactly what that sound was.
All right, where is it?
Corvo, where is it?
I don't know what you're looking at, but I hope you actually
know what you're doing.
Okay, bad, yeah, bro.
It's not fair!
We had a secret agent!
I'm like, we literally had a plant!
That fucked us over!
We should have...
Our competent leaders all died under mysterious
circumstances.
That could have been anything.
That could have been a bird!
You know the birds can like repeat stuff?
The birds repeat mods?
No more tea.
You don't know that!
We killed three and the dragons.
We don't know that.
There's no proof.
They don't even have stream proof.
There's no proof that the New World goons did it.
Guys, I lost our leader.
Where did our leader go?
Guys, where did he go?
Guys, where did Corvo go?
Are we following the right people?
Guys, guys, I think we lost the leader.
Guys, we lost the leader, guys.
Guys, guys, where did he go?
Guys, where did he go, guys?
I lost him.
Where did the leader...
Guys, where did he go?
Where did the bear go?
Oh, no.
Guys, I don't see him.
Guys, I don't see the bear anymore.
I don't...
I don't see him, guys.
Guys, we lost...
Oh, no.
the leader guys are we gonna fight guys i have a feeling
none of you guys actually know where he is guys i have a
feeling none of you guys actually know where where corvo is
you guys how do we teleport guys how do we teleport but not
tp all where's corvo where is he that's not corvo they're
just building new they're just building new towers
I'm not blind.
I don't see him.
Oh, is he over there?
Did you guys... You guys know?
Wait, he knows!
He knows!
He actually knows!
Wait.
New leader.
Guys.
Where did the leader go?
Guys, where did the leader go?
Where did the new leader go?
He took us to water and I lost him!
No, I'm gonna die!
Oh, oh god.
Guys, guys, where's the new leader?
Guys, we lost him.
He took us to the water and he disappeared.
Oh, wait, no, there he is.
There he is.
New leader.
He knows.
Do you actually know?
Are you fucking with us too?
your new leader do you know does he know guys we need to
kill the ender dragon please like
all right the only leader all right show me the ender pearl
if you want to be a leader you have to have the ender pearl
on you right now I need to see a pearl I need to see I need
to see the pearl whoever has the pearl give me the leader
who whoever has the pearl gets to be the leader do none of
you have pearls dude I'm sorry The Ender Eye.
Dude, none of you.
The Eye of Ender.
Dude, that is not the Eye of...
None of you have Eye of Ender.
Dude, none of you.
Guys, I don't think any of you...
Guys.
I think...
All right.
Okay.
I have I I think they at none of them actually knew I don't
think anybody none of them actually knew all right I left
them stranded in the middle of nowhere that's their new home
now that's that's that's their new I picked the wrong team
That's That's their new home now That's where they're gonna
live Alright Who has the eye of Ender
Do any Trangoon have The eye of Ender Anybody You guys are
the people I left stranded How did you guys get back here?
I left you guys stranded.
Alright.
Okay, teleport.
How do I do this?
Tele- TP.
TP.
Alright, who?
What, Orca?
Alright.
We did it, guys.
Guys, we did it.
Summon the Ender Dragon.
What the fuck who died?
Summon the Ender Dragon!
The queen is here now.
The queen is here.
I demand the new world.
The queen is here to get the taxes.
Wait, no!
No!
The revolution has started!
Oh!
Oh my god.
They try to tea party me.
They're trying to tea party me.
Oh my god.
Those new world goons.
They're crazy.
They're savages.
They're fucking savages over there.
Those new world goons.
Oh my god.
This is why we left them.
Guys, this is why we left them.
on that island this is exactly why not you guys old world
goons my old world goons don't worry we won't let the new
world goons do this to us guys my old world goons we will
prosper i might not command the new world anymore but we are
not savages like them we're not
We are the old world for a reason.
We have our other territories.
We have our other territories, guys.
The new world is not the only...
The new world is not the only place that we have colonized.
We have other places.
So do not worry.
I believe in us.
we have the rest of europe guys
the goddamn old world thinking they can fight back to their
queen how dare they how fucking dare they guys i should not
the pp tower was not a good form of government like i have
learned that now We have Germany.
Exactly.
We literally have Germany and Lithuania.
Luna,
thank you for the super sticker.
Thank you.
It's okay.
The new world is still under my rule.
New world, if you hear me now, new world.
I'm broadcasting my message to across the ocean.
New World, if you hear me, just so you know, I still, I have
owner power.
I can destroy everything you love, New World.
I can bring Flint over to the New World.
So don't piss me off.
I still have perms over the New World.
Alright, let's see.
I need to eat.
Alright.
I golden.
It'll be fine if I eat a golden.
A golden.
A glistening melon.
It'll be fine.
It'll be fine, guys.
I want to see how my dock is going.
My old world dock.
Alright, let's see.
Throw the taxes into the ocean.
They can't do that.
Like I said, I have old world power.
We're back in Doki Land.
All right, how's the dock going?
Poor attempt made.
What the fuck?
Who do I can't advertise?
What?
Who took the taxes?
Somebody took the taxes.
Who yanked my taxes?
This has to be the new world's doing.
There's no way.
This has to.
fucking savages i can't believe it they teapotting me they
actually teapotting me in the port
they dumped it to the harbor those oh my god guys i know i
said like all dragoons are created equally guys i'm gonna
make a speech i know i said all dragoons are created equally
i need to be those new world goons there's a reason why we
banished them all the way back there I knew not doing public
housing in the new world was a good idea now they'll know if
they try and ask for me to give them like to give them
government funding I will never give them government funding
You old roguins, you guys, you guys are special.
Those new world goons, I know I said all dragoons are
created equally, but the new world goons, they are not as
equal.
Are we really gonna let them, are we really gonna let them
dump our taxes into the ocean?
some goods are more equal than others oh my god that's fun
though lego land what the fuck where's lego land is this
lego land there's savages savages barely even human
oh my god they try to fight back to your queen how could
they oh my god hey guys what the fuck how do you guys get
here what the fuck did you guys jump on top wait how did you
guys do that wait what oh i thought you kept build there all
right guys i also want to slash sit i'm gonna call it here
it's been fun i definitely had we had no bgm after after
what happened um after what happened today i'll put the pgm
back on but after what happened with being led in the wild
goose chase i have got rid of the bgm because that's what we
deserve but i had a lot of fun with all you guys today i
cannot wait to play more on the dragon server in the future
um and also improve the server for all of you guys I can't
wait to improve the server.
If you guys have, like, any notes you guys want to do, like,
stuff to do, improve the server.
Like, any ideas you want to add.
We're going to implement a better chat system so people can
chat with others, within groups, within factions.
But you have any ideas or anything regarding, like, how to
improve this Dragoon server.
Feel free to comment on the VOD itself, and then we'll look
through the VOD.
And then, obviously, I want to host, like, events.
I want to redecorate some parts here.
I want to have more quality of life changes, but I
definitely had...
my god i had a lot of fun
i had so much fun guys i'm really happy that we finally have
our server now um why is there a boat here i'm really happy
that we finally got our server up and going and i'm so
excited to see what you guys are gonna build uh but yes
everybody i'm gonna call it here guys i'm gonna call it here
um as always everybody stay hydrated posture check and move
around to get that blood flowing and if you stay up for me
head to bed because you deserve it i'll see you guys next
time everybody bye guys bye